RESENTED BY GEORGIA NATURAL
GAS.
WE WILL HEAD UP TO KELLY.
AT THE STATE FARM ARENA.
THAT IS COMING UP AT THE END OF
THE THIRD QUARTER.
JUST OVER TWO MINUTES AGO IN
THE PERIOD.
JIMMY BUTLER SHOOTS OVER  TRAE
YOUNG.
REBOUND, DE'ANDRE HUNTER.
MIAMI HAS DROPPED OFF TO 46%,
OVERALL.
TRAE YOUNG, MID FLOOR.
JIMMY BUTLER ON HIM.
JIMMY, GOING FOR THE STEAL.
COMES UP WITH IT.
TRAE YOUNG  TIES HIM UP.
ALSO BY TRAE YOUNG.
TAKING ON JIMMY BUTLER.
>> Brian: GO AHEAD AND FLEX,
TRAE YOUNG.
TELL HIM THAT YOU'RE NOT TO BE
PLAYED WITH.
>> Bob: JIMMY BUTLER, OF
COURSE, ONE OF THE BEST
DEFENDERS IN THE NBA.
FOUR-TIME ALL NBA -- ALL
DEFENSIVE TEAM MEMBER.
HE WENT AFTER THE BALL.
TRAE YOUNG NEVER GAVE UP.
>> Brian: I LIKE THE HUSTLE BY
HIM.
THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT TO SEE.
TALK ABOUT SENSE